so my log we have guns everything in the
house dog right so the alarm when our
guards came Velasquez yeah Francis and
Ghani they're all kind of cramped
Francis in Gatos my security guard but
hopefully no wrestlers robotic dog
wrestlers breaking yo what are you gonna
do him anyways so we'll run around
Andres see what do you see a team six on
top of them no no just like a bunch of
CrossFitters like we're just gonna run
around to your time take you down
anyways so then then steal all Brandon
stuff so uh we didn't shut the garage
door very good like you wouldn't like it
was locked be now sometimes it locks but
it sticks against the yeah like Keith so
the wind picked up in the alarms on so
if any doors open alarm
so I'm sleeping three in the morning the
wind picked up the alarm goes off well I
didn't know that I assume someone's
breaking in and you go into Navy SEAL
mode yeah I got the [ __ ] yeah I was
so scared yeah because you think someone
just and if they're ballsy enough to
come in there gangster that's right
that's why I'm I'm here alright
yeah I'm caught I'm in my [ __ ]
underoos with a giant shotgun it's like
I came and I don't want to do this man
yelling yeah cops come the [ __ ] goes
well did you look around the area go not
really I stayed on the stairs waiting
for him to come out to blast them in the
face he goes giant Brandon yeah then
they knew who I am he goes hmm
yeah the next time I probably look
around cuz it looks like the wind blew
out the door open
really he was mad yeah more was positive
that's what happened there's no way into
here just that way man I'm embarrassing
you
that's alright I like the stories about
like there was that twelve year old girl
and she would compete in shotgun like
you know those hips shooting the skeet
shooting things she was like I have
national junior national chanter a
couple guys broke in they had killed
somebody before they came in and they
had bad intentions she was 12 she was
those two men have bad intentions and
they come in they chased her upstairs
she got your shotgun that competition
yeah a little yeah dad
in case of lead poisoning time out she
played some Nintendo duck hunt sure did
that human case case led time on human
hunt got one of them at the top of the
stairs and then another guy was at that
way so so let's move on to steep a steep
a what can you say about steep a man
steep a Miocic is he the best of all
time I think so I think so in history I
think it's you it's the same thing kind
of what's going on with LeBron same
thing happened not too much with Jordan
but really LeBron really with Kobe but
with a Brett Favre when you have these
greats these guys who you know the
conversation of greatest of all time you
don't appreciate him till they're
retired and you look back over their
body of work when you're in the moment
and they're playing every night or their
players are fighting every few months or
you know they won this Super Bowl they
did this you take it for granted until
they stop and then you go back know oh
my God look how good that guy woods
that's Steve Bay that's LeBron right now
so steep a you know the history books
and sweet tough to beat this record
especially with the current UFC
heavyweight class with these dinosaurs
in there ain't no one beaten this record
with the most consecutive title defenses
of all time and you look at Steve Bay's
record man he's had a tough go meaning
he's beat the who's who the one fight or
the two fights that he lost he redeemed
the JDS fighting off his true fight was
that the bump in a row when he's at nine
and one who's kind of his first tough
fight you know so yeah I like downside
ground I don't care
I do not care then after that after that
lost he was gonna fight Roy Nelson which
he beats him which is a huge feather in
your cap
then he goes on to fight Gabriel Gonzaga
who was always a perennial gatekeeper
then he you know the Fabio Maldonado
fight I don't know what fabulous doing
that fight and then he fights Junior dos
Santos to a decision which it was
fighting the Knights in Phoenix Arizona
that's in 2014 most people thought steep
and won that fight anyways then he goes
on to fight mark hunt beats double
breaks off mark hunt in Australia and
then they give him on air lossky necks
he torches our last game 54 seconds then
they give for breezy over doom for the
heavyweight title he goes to Brazil
nothing that I want you to think about
this so he fights
our hunt he fights Mark Hunt in
Australia so you know he's facing some
adversity there Danny fights for briefs
over doom in Brazil for BC has a huge
name in Brazil at for his first time
fighting for the belt he starches for
bricio in 2 minutes and 47 seconds then
he gets Oscar over him in Cleveland his
hometown and it's fight of the night and
it's an amazing performance I was
getting a little bit of trouble but he
still ends up being Alistair Overeem one
of the greatest riders if not the
greatest heavyweight strike of all time
then he gets to fight Junior dos Santos
who he previously lost to quote-unquote
lost to to redeem himself and he
starches Junior dos Santos who's in the
conversation of top 5 greatest of all
time and then next for him as he fights
the walking legend hype man the boogey
man the bane of the UFC Francis in Ghana
who no one has figured out who everyone
was terrified of who no one wanted to
fight and he absolutely wrecks him
wrecks that dude destroys him we have
Francis reconsider his entire career we
have France want to go back to camera
and street fight again in the dirt
coming here and you know and then I was
explained everything for all my fans
because here we come and do clear
everything yeah and then let and then I
I really I really happy people I can
explain myself in English you know
people don't Iike you you don't can
don't know what cyber say and then I'm
getting bad at each time you know I
proved my English you play better even
now than last time you yeah she's been
yelling at me now the neighbors are like
Jesus no I'm getting better than I think
it's bad it's this is really important
for my fans and they're sending me and
you know what I'm saying whatever I
thinking and then I come here and they
cleared everything it's to be when I
said thanks for the opportunity always
man always appreciate you going I don't
think you have Crohn's I don't know but
I don't think I think it's a phase I'll
be alright yeah yeah I'll be alright
it was so funny yesterday man I'm
would that was that yes yes yesterday I
met with that stylist for efore the girl
I met with him to have a pic of the know
I'll have them send me insane get super
mad you hit so bad I'm already mad I
can't wait to post the fake just for you
I think of you Ben
when he came in it was so funny too
frantic he comes in he's like this top
right designer stylist shout out to warn
he comes in tall handsome joke tall six
five in shape from London knows this
fashion like a [ __ ] I come in
there's just all this stuff laid out and
I'm looking and cuz you have to eat
nicely grandma's got a dress pretty nice
we don't have to wear all black now like
the Golden Globes so you can get you can
peacock a little bit sure he knows my
style yeah
and he goes he goes I just want you to
look around just look around tell me
what sticks out to you and I go right to
this coat I should go tania's I knew
you're gonna pick that that's the one I
was thinking oh it really goes I don't
know why you have me I have no idea why
you even have me here I went right this
is the one is yes and I'll try this on I
put on use I came and like it's you
right now I went really
here's a Caitlyn with you right now I
can't even okay yeah here's all these
shoes he has off his shoes I'm wearing
no sock loafers with a tuxedo pant right
he's tailoring in the pants and you know
what you go switch shoes and I go god i
think these egos this is the exact
outfit I picked up I went dude we're too
good together
oh we're to God and then oh boy can I
ask you this
it was on accident though you know when
you're supposed to go like that when you
miss you for you sister I went like this
alright now do you think that that your
girl will be willing to share tiger like
on the weekends or how is that going to
come when you move so funny though
and then I then I beeline from there I'm
in escrow on the house and the guy
running the inspection goes bro
I listen to the show big guys like big
tough guy yeah listen to the show
you know I know Callens looking for a
fight and I'd be honored to take that
fight now you looking for a fight I'm
there to run through the chimney and do
I was Tobias looking for a fight and it
sounds leaking for one I'm not he goes
I'm your guy went no no doubt yeah I
don't know he's any big tough guy tough
dude yeah I'm not gonna and I know
nothing about him let's put on some
headgear and really bang it out what
stuff dude absolutely not doctor right
box his whole life like I'll get caught
like Stone Cold Steve Austin you be
honest I'm not fighting you everybody
out there me and [ __ ] are gonna spar
he's just messing her house what da [ __ ]
he goes full thing a week training camp
will film it we'll do it the whole Emily
uh dude I check out that leak over there